definitely can't see which one he is but
he's out there
Selena Gomez had Nicola Peltz show
Brooklyn Beckham support at his soccer
game proving their throttles going
strong we and love each other's company
the only murders in the building star
documented their night out which also
included her little sister Grace
definitely can't see which one he is but
he's out there
at one point cell gets kind of confused
about what sport her pal Brooklyn's
playing what are you doing
watching
um Brooklyn play baseball oh it's soccer
you crazy you know the sport Brooklyn's
Father David Beckham is known for
Beckham's free kick
I like to feel that I still impress my
kids all the time but Brooklyn this game
didn't exactly end with a win so we lost
but I'm pretty sure it was rich
footballer not baseball player that's
what I said oh my goodness back to that
whole throttle thing it started when
cell joined the couple for a tropical
New Year's Eve getaway
[Music]
alongside these cozy picks together
Selena embraced being the Third Wheel
writing fine call us a throuple hashtag
forever plus one and Nicola doubled down
on that commenting facts
foreign
[Music]
are besties
the two are featured all over each
other's social media feeds so as soon as
we find out who you are trust you will
be dealt with period it's really cool
it's no different when Brooklyn joins in
on the fun
[Music]
Brooklyn's truly like my best friend and
I feel like I'm living with my best
friend and also like the love of my life
so it's been nice you have to marry your
best friend so to sum it up we're all
here for Selena Nicola and Brooklyn as a
foreign